[Music]
get your footwork the first few
techniques and then didn't
look at your footwork again as the
technique progressed
[Music]
yeah remember beginner 101 pay attention
to the footwork follow the footwork
first get the footwork down and then
move up the body concentrate on that
foot work especially the style of the
foot
meaning not stepped here step there
but how did you step there was it
circular did it sink did it rise what
was the tempo of it all of that kind of
stuff makes the world of difference for
your application it's just that old
adage right if you're if the ground
floor is crap then whatever you build on
it is not going to stay where you want
it to be it's going to be crap too so
get that base down and don't get stuck
on the points in space or the points on
the mat pay attention to the manner do
you guys understand that there's a lot
of you will pick your feet up like you
remind me of lurch or Boris Karloff
Frankenstein and I never walk like that
okay there's something about
yes yeah I'm gonna try to dress that for
a really long time and I wonder if
there's some lyoha we kind of unravel
like what is it about that particular
position it's you know it's the position
of ultimate vulnerability to expose
yourself in this manner is you can look
at it that it is the opposite of the
startle response which is the fear
response so the fear response for those
that have it they're going to close off
the arteries and veins in the neck so
like this I'm afraid asleep right your
hands wherever they walk are going to
come in so you shield your heart your
lungs right your vital organs you shield
themselves you hold your breath so you
don't inhale anything that has the
possibility of killing you you shut your
eyes so your eyes are protected you get
in and this is the exact opposite
[Music]
if you look at religious iconography
you're not going to see this one did you
have it you're going to see this way it
is it really the case that it's that
heavens up there or is it the case that
I remain centered in this exposure did
we all as non-practitioners look at that
statue and what are they looking instead
of going what vulnerability
so there's ways that you can kind of
help yourself get there we do things
where we put the yoga block behind your
back area diaphragm area and you start
opening up it's a kind of modified
corpse pose and you release and you
release there so for someone who is
always on a desk especially a desk that
has deadlines attached to it which is
most of us that exercises vital to
re-open everything because you're
starting to have a 24/7 startle response
and various yogic poses do the same
thing they open up your body right and
those are very important but you're not
going to stretch your way to to
reconciling fear okay you have to get at
the heart of it which is that acceptance
okay
it's if when when you have the
acceptance you're not truly vulnerable
the the the view of vulnerability or
risk exposure is from our unenlightened
perspective to the person whose
reconcile itself and fear
it's just relaxation it's just who they
are you you brought up a question on on
text about the you Kimmy and I didn't I
kept giving you different answers I know
you were looking for some straight
answers but your answers weren't your
questions were leading to answers that
would not correct and they're related to
this
so when UK has to push and UK gives up
their Center that's from the point of
view of the unawakened practitioner from
the awaken practitioner give up what's
that mean give up means loss do you get
that and loss means I don't want that I
want no loss this can't be you kidding
me
so it's not that you when you're asking
me those ultimate questions I can't
answer them as yeah give up your Center
to get it that's not it I didn't give up
my Center it's still me I'm accepting
what's happening I'm upside down I'm
flying through the air at any moment I
can turn this technique around and draw
a weapon land reverse the technique
but as a pointer as a beginner pointer
upaya you're often told to give up your
Center give up your coz you're like
holding it like you're schmegle right
you know and you you won't you won't
give it up and that is so far away from
those those icons you get it
so you're told at the beginner level hey
let go of that ring for a second okay
let me show you what true invisibility
is that kind of let me show you what
true safety is it's a very East Asian
idea like everyone wants to be safe and
this East Asia has learned to its
philosophers yeah you can't be safe by
resisting you can't that's that's not
how safety is going to be yours because
you're not always going to be able to
resist forces will be stronger forces
will have initiatives surprised you
cannot survive like that all that we can
do is make ourselves unable to be
attacked when I'm unable to be attacked
then I cannot be defeated that it's a
philosophical position then you as an as
a beginner will tend to go away so
unable to be attacked that means going
faster like that's you trying to be
stronger again
no it means acceptance they they they
and you here in your training will prove
that philosophical position over and
over and have it proved before your eyes
over and over you want to go that way go
that way you're going to see I'm not
more vulnerable and you're going to see
you're not more vulnerable
but at first it's a face it's a faith
statement isn't it because our fear is
convinced you want me to be vulnerable
and I don't I don't believe it
[Music]
this area since they talked a lot about
faith that's not even was not Christian
didn't but he faith was huge the student
had to be able to suspend their own
inclinations their own sense of reality
for at least a moment to see ah you said
the reality is also possible just that
it's also possible
if you when you do that it will speak
for herself it also works better
so if you take this technique you're all
trying to get this technique but you
can't find the complete forfeiting of
control that allows the arm to actually
become under your control and I can't
make you right I've seen teachers
including my own go ahead and do it
wrong again you've heard me even say
that to some of you that's a kind of
Timmy
boom wake up but you don't really learn
that way you have to in your own head go
I'm gonna put Dave on the shelf and I'm
gonna try this that's all I'm gonna do
I'm gonna let it go by they go by wait
get it
[Music]
and I I think that my own practice has
evolved the more capacity for yen energy
has been achieved and I know that sounds
weird because maybe as a deshi you focus
in on the power you might feel it's
attractive it's luring but you what you
need to focus in is on the void so I'll
share with the older people have known
this story but it's very sensei was mr.
Boyd I think he quit he fight if you
ever see a tape you'll see he's not
really interested in the in the throw
part at all and a lot of times he
stopped the technique he was already
starting the next rap but you made his
tech technique look weird if he didn't
know what he was doing I always thought
of him as a Nutty Professor
he had a laboratory and we walked in
like the wrong class at the University
and you thought you know is this
chemistry 101 and and you have this mad
scientist oh yeah and you're like no
yes but it's chemistry you know that's
what it felt like so you kinda had to
imagine that I'm going to learn by
watching the scientist because he's not
going to do a chapter 1 and a chapter 2
there's not going to be a preface and
there's no bibliography at the
and he's not going to even grade you so
he would do his techniques this is this
is what his and then no one would get it
right no one would get it so he's go
like this and then no one would get that
and then that was it you'll see you at
the end of the hour
nice and he do this he he he
acknowledges to me in conversation that
the people that really wanted to throw
you know like boom kaboom hated his
classes because you were gonna do that
you get it and he said that they can't
really throw it because they can't even
they can't do that so you need to do
that so I'm a young deshi and I hear
that what will I do will I do what the
masses do and go hey I just want to toss
people around or do I go here's this guy
with decades and he's telling me that I
need to do this to be able to really do
that and he's telling me they can't
really do that because they can't do
this so I'm gonna believe him I'm gonna
believe him so I
spent some time with him I went to all
his classes and we did all of that stuff
barely ever a technique he got really
into this Taizo bacchiocchi sabaki
that's all you did and then a lot of
sacred geometry stuff in our
conversations off the mat which were
even stranger you know figure eight
stars golden means was odd he started
getting into all that stuff and you know
he would carry around Tibetan Buddhist
ritual implement instruments and it's
like this what is it what does that mean
to you guys you go do it you've got a
guy they say yeah it's not going to do
anything for you it's like a sebou T
sebou T is the greatest exercise for
gaining the strength that we feel in
koku but only if you know how to do coke
you otherwise it's a waste of time
so yeah yeah he's doing this but as a
new person I just see
so I could go he's crazy or I could have
the faith that every day she needs
because every day she is going from
basically not knowing to knowing and you
can't get there but through a leap of
faith so I went to all his classes did
all his drills there's like no advance
people ever come to these things right
he even said it dad they don't come they
don't like me they don't like what I
have to do what I have to teach even at
summer camp
they don't come there when I remember
one very very skilled senior
practitioner she was teaching she was
going to teach the class and I I'm low
and I don't talk to her and she could
kill me and I'm just like gonna go take
her class and she's like hey I'm gonna
do your sensei stuff make sure I do it
right and I remember going wow no no
wonder you kick ass do you get it cuz
she she was interested in that detail
right to the point where she would tell
right loli can she say day make sure I
do it right which was mind-blowing to me
of like man that's the spirit right
there
and she would she called me up as the
demo partner which is terrifying as a
lowly can she say at these things right
and she didn't have but one speed kill
and it was with the joke and since I
started using the Joe to to reference
the hips and then her Joe is just flying
that mine midsection skewering me and
still going was that right
but I then go to Japan and I just did
his drills every day before training I
said you should have a half hour of
history sensei's drills I don't know I
didn't have any aspirations for them
just do the drills so I would make up
you know a rep schedule you can do this
drill for five minutes then this drill
for five minutes then that drill for
five minutes and I would just watch the
clock or set my watch or whatever right
and that was just what I did and I when
I watched some of the difficulties that
we have here they are about weight
shifting aren't they you don't shift
your weight properly they are about
rotation you don't have any hip rotation
in this technique they're too linear you
can't find the circle right that would
that lurch walking that is because you
don't know how to shift your weight so
you don't have any actual linear thrust
to your forward progression you what
you're doing instead is falling forward
when you fall forward
you can't displace what's in front of
you you actually will get displaced
instead
so I've recommended those drills to
everyone here at one time or another but
how many have said every time I show up
I'm going to show up a half hour early
and I'm gonna do those drills
it's that PHA thing
that's the that's the void right when
earlier I said you can't walk into the
boy that's what you guys want to do you
want to walk into I'm gonna do a little
that time and put my toe in first that's
why I had laughs is because if you only
knew you can't put your toe in the void
that does not possible the void is you
see where you're standing
whoa it disappeared we can't put your
toe in it and you guys keep wanting to
try that you want it to make sense and
then you're going to do it how does that
work it can't makes it if it made sense
to you already
why would you want it you already have
it
so we'll go back them we'll introduce
this area sensei's drills and then
you'll do what you want with them I just
I tell you I he was right if you can't
do these movements you really can't do
the techniques you can and as as that
mad scientist that's what he did he
wanted to know what is the heart
I must have okay and he he he went to
the physical level it's where you start
there if I can't if I can't shift my
weight correctly forget trying to get
out of the way hey that's that getting
out of the way is so much more
complicated than just can you shift your
weight don't have a reason just ask that
question and then works work on it don't
don't do et me don't enter I just want
to see you move forward
entering is very complicated entering
onto a ponent very complicated but can
you just take a step forward in the
right way can you take a step backwards
don't 10 con I just want to see if you
can take a step backwards in the right
way